today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
all right guys we have to get ahead of a
major propaganda story that is
breaking today and happening exactly as
predicted
i have no special psychic insight i just
knew it was going to happen because we
understand how donald trump operates we
have received the estimated
third quarter gdp number for the united
states
and annualized gdp growth for q3
was an astounding incredible
33.1 gdp
growth wow and if you look at just that
number
at a superficial level turn your brain
off
throw logic into the trash and do no
research whatsoever
you might say this country is doing
unbelievably well economically we are
back wow this is unbelievable
and you're going to get hit by some
insane propaganda
from donald trump and his campaign in
the next five days leading up to the
election
which will try to convince you of
exactly that it is bs
and you must be prepared for it so gdp
changes are relative to the prior
status quo of the gdp
remember that in the second quarter due
to coronavirus
usgdp dropped more than 31 percent
that's a record we have never had as big
a gdp
decrease as we had in the second quarter
of this year
so when we say gdp is up 33
in the third quarter it is up relative
to the record decline that we had in the
second quarter
before this year the biggest ever
decrease to the gdp was in 1921's
second quarter of 28.6 the biggest
increase was actually 40
in 1879 q4 the country was very
different then it's not even really
relevant to compare that but okay
and just as i predicted three months ago
when the second quarter numbers came out
donald trump tweeted this morning
exactly what i told you he would i've
been preparing you for this for three
months
donald trump tweeting quote gdp number
just announced
biggest and best in the history of our
country
and not even close next year will be
fantastic
however sleepy joe biden and his
proposed record-setting tax increase
would kill it all
so glad this great gdp number came out
before november 3rd yeah
he is glad so let's understand what's
going on here be
armed with the numbers if you work for
me imagine i hire you to be my
you know hype man or woman
or whatever and i pay you a salary of
fifty thousand dollars a year
okay if after the first year i give you
a thirty one percent
cut that lowers your salary salary from
fifty thousand dollars a year to thirty
four thousand five hundred
and then the next year i say hey i'm
going to give you a 33
raise this is a huge record raise i've
never given anybody a 33
raise you're going to get it and after
the 31
cut and the 33 raise you are actually
still well below your original
salary of 50 000 now
this is exactly what they're doing here
there are people who do not
understand math who think well we went
down
31 and up 33 we're back
we're better than ever we're recovered
but of course that's not the case
remember that if something goes down 50
percent
it then needs to go up a hundred percent
to get back to where we were i mean just
let's apply this to make it easy to the
number one hundred which we're putting
up on the screen
if you start with a hundred and lose
thirty one percent you're down to 69.
that's easy if you then get 33 percent
back from that 69 you're
only up to about 91
so you are still about eight and a half
percent below where you started so
now six months after
the end of the first quarter we had the
second quarter
and the third quarter and we are still
down 8.23 percent
from where we started on april 1st this
is a
stunning economic contraction and case
in point
the gdp after this explosive
record-setting growth that donald trump
is bragging about
our gdp is now back up to where it was
two and a half years ago in the first
quarter of 2018.
you are going to get hit very very hard
with propaganda and talking points
but now you understand the math of it
one of the ways that the right
distorts reality is to ignore the recent
past and
if you look just at q3 wow
33 percent up but that's only if you
ignore
the second quarter i'm not expecting the
media to highlight this and to make it
clear
and um you need to come armed with the
information yourself
because this is trump's last stand folks
um 80 million people have already voted
we have five days until the election
this is i told you this would be the
last ditch effort to say
we did it don't fall for it don't let
other people fall for it friends don't
let friends fall
for obviously bad math that's gdp let's
now talk about coronavirus and the stock
market
the stock market is not the economy many
people
own no stocks at all many people own
very little but the stock market is one
indicator that we look at and the stock
market
has collapsed this week as coronavirus
continues to explode
and ravage the country and as donald
trump still has no plan
nor even any interest in dealing with
the virus at this point
either we keep falling more and more
into a dystopian nightmare with the
pandemic
or donald trump gets replaced it's one
of the two trump is not going to fix
this
all right but the stock market is
absolutely
imploding the first three days this week
the dow closing last week
at roughly 28 300
monday down 600 points tuesday down
another couple hundred points yesterday
falling off a cliff down nearly a
thousand points the decline for these
first three days of the week
about 1700 points now the specifics of
the impact of the stock market being
down are heavily
concentrated among companies and rich
people who own the vast majority of
stock that is very true
but this is a signal about the
confidence in the american economy
and because of the virus confidence is
very low we are seeing record
coronavirus
numbers we have a third spike already
reaching
and surpassing the single day case highs
of late july
we've had over 80 000 cases multiple
days over the last few weeks
over the last week rather and even
though trump said we would not see more
deaths
the seven day average of deaths in the
united states
has been starting to climb since the
middle of october remember
deaths used to lag cases by two to three
weeks
now that we're better at treating the
virus death slag cases by a little bit
more
even people who die or staying alive a
little bit longer as
sort of morose as that is and
hospitalizations
are peaking again and potentially on
their way to the highest peak we've seen
thus far
if and when the hospitals get full you
will see the death rate grow up dramatic
go up dramatically and we still have no
plan
the stock market is rattled because
there is still no plan
trump bemoaning that the media is
talking about the pandemic
saying at his rallies and tweeting many
times some version of this tweet from
yesterday where he said quote
kovidkovkovid is the unified chant of
the fake news lame stream media
they will talk about nothing else until
november 4th when the election will be
hopefully over
then they talk then then the talk will
be how low the death rate is
plenty of hospital rooms and many tests
of young people
he's living in a fantasy world and we
knew
they were going to go with the idea of
let people get used to a thousand deaths
a day
let it become normal and while that is
completely immoral
it actually might have worked were it
only for the deaths
but this is a real economics lesson
which anthony scaramucci pointed out on
twitter
anthony scaramucci former guest on this
program check out that interview former
white house coms director
scaramucci tweeted economics lesson for
the soon-to-be ex-president
the virus needed to be contained to help
the economy and stock markets
federal stimulus would never be enough
you crushed the stock market and the
economy by not understanding this
trump thought for political gain i will
ignore it
the problem is the economy and the stock
market won't ignore it
and they will notice that even if they
don't care or agree to ignore
the deaths they are having a massive
impact on the economy and as europe is
in its second spike we're already in our
third
and it is getting very ugly we need a
plan we need someone to take control of
the pandemic trump can't do it
he's also not trying they've given up
remember over the last
weekend trump's deranged masculist
chief of staff mark meadows actually
said
we're not going to control the pandemic
check this out from cnn
so here's what we have to do we're not
going to control the pandemic we are
going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations because
it is a contagious virus just like the
but why not make
efforts to contain it well we are making
efforts to contain it by running all
over the country not wearing a mask
that's what the vice president back and
forth let me just say this
is what we need to do is make sure that
we have
the proper mitigation factors whether
it's therapies or vaccines or
treatments they've given up that's it
what we have ahead of us
may be if we replace donald trump with
joe biden
is that joe biden will take the pandemic
seriously and in general
american stock markets and economies do
better under democratic presidents
that's a historical reality
and that's also what we're counting on
at this point but we have to make it
happen
otherwise this this is horrible
this may only be the beginning if we
don't remove
donald trump let me know your thoughts
and reaction
i'm on twitter at d pacman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that membership is the number
one funding source
for our little show you can sign up
at joinpacman.com i invite you to join
the discussion
with at this point about 25 000
other viewers and listeners of the david
pakman show on our subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t i want to
highlight a few posts from the subreddit
user reflex point
pointed out uh very astutely i'm
depressed that the race is even this
close
given how horrible of a person trump is
i just can't wrap my mind around the
fact that biden
is only up by nine points nationally and
could potentially lose the race if there
are huge polling errors
in battleground states it's nauseating
disgusting and depressing
that this many americans after four
years of what we've seen
want four more years of it i'm so far
past saying we need to understand what
drove these people to trump
he bullied gretchen whitmer who was
threatened to be kidnapped
and murdered by right-wing armed thugs
that alone should cost him the election
let alone the ten thousand other things
he's done at this point
i can barely even remember anymore
because they were so numerous yeah and
this gets back to this idea that win or
lose
after the election we have 60 million
plus
trumpists in this country that are you
know debasing education
um completely divorced from the
realities of
how the world works i mean but the the
whatever focus you want to
to pick there for whatever slice of
those 60 million people you're you're
more concerned with that is a real
problem and
trump should be down 80 point i mean
nobody should be voting for donald trump
if the world makes that made sense
nobody would be voting for donald trump
uh user pumpkin pie
666 pumpkin pie 666 says very
aggressively
you are politically useless if you don't
vote
it doesn't matter what your views are
how much david pakman you listen to
how much news you consume or how active
you are on political twitter if you
don't cast a ballot
voting is the only viable path to change
in the direction we want
trump can still win all of the protests
impeachment all of the backlash against
trump
will have been totally meaningless if we
don't actually show up and vote him out
you're not a hero for not voting you're
irrelevant you're politically useless no
matter how informed you are on the
issues
the left may pull a 2016 and
self-immolate again by refusing to
participate
don't be one of those people or the next
four years may be worse
than the last four i don't know that i
would word it as aggressively
but the sentiment there is fair which is
there's much more that we can do in
addition to voting but we all have to
vote
that's the starting point if we're not
voting what are we doing
join the discussion i'm inviting you
at davidpakman.com reddit
donald trump held another series of
rallies yesterday
and at this sort of late stage in the
election with just
five days remaining and nearly 80
million votes already cast
the rallies are becoming dramatically
more unhinged
you can track it on a day-to-day basis
now part of it may be exhaustion on
donald trump's behalf part of it maybe
desperation but yesterday
was wacky and out there now first of all
a really strange moment in arizona trump
brought out congressman kevin mccarthy
who i guess wants to be speaker of the
house if republicans take the house next
week
which they won't republicans are not
taking the house next week
and he said he wouldn't bang
nancy pelosi with the gavel a bizarre
moment
it'll be before we swear in the
president again
but the reason why i want you to come i
want you to watch
nancy pelosi hand me that gavel
and i promise you this
[Applause]
i won't bang her with it but i'll bang
the end to the socialism
and yes to america really strange stuff
there and trump now
is regularly complaining about the
weather and the temperature at his
rallies
it's either too cold or too hot or too
windy
arizona i guess was too hot for him and
i'm sitting in the hottest sun i've ever
felt
this is hot
my last stop also in your great state it
had a different problem the sun was hot
i've never seen wind like that
it's lucky i don't need teleprompters
like sleepy joe
because the teleprompters were falling
down they were going all over the place
i was getting a headache i'm trying to
look
but i have a good memory i remember
things
now he said he doesn't need a
teleprompter
while using a teleprompter in that clip
but
is anybody else sick of the whining this
is the whiniest president i can remember
leslie stahl wasn't fair and twitter's
not
fair and the fake news isn't fair and
it's too
cold and now it's too hot and it's too
windy and it's too sunny and i'm too
sweaty
this is the most privileged man in
america
and he thinks he's the biggest victim he
can't stop complaining
in this next clip trump actually doesn't
know what city he's in
this is this is the best trump doesn't
know what city he's in
and even though he criticizes biden for
using a prompter
he struggles to read the name of the
city he's in off of the prompter because
it's
windy mesa to human and from phoenix
to right here in bullhead
sucker is moving so much i see pull that
i'm trying to go up and is my head
moving up and down like this
you did a great job of anchoring these
things fellas a great job
yeah trump who has been accusing his
opponent of cognitive decline
doesn't know what city he's in unless he
reads it off a prompter
which he criticizes joe biden for using
and trump then claims
this is now in bullhead city arizona
trump still ridiculing masks as we have
more than 233
000 coronavirus deaths
[Applause]
with sleepy joe there'd be no
graduations no weddings no thanksgiving
they're already talking about no
thanksgiving
and in california you have a special
mask you cannot
under any circumstances take it off you
have to eat through the mask and say
right right charlie it's it's a very
complex
mechanism and they don't realize those
germs they go through it like nothing
they look at you with that contraption
and they say that's an easy one i'll go
right through with the food
now how about california though where
you're supposed to eat
with the mask can't take it up okay so
then the audio problem started with
insane wind
and people on stage behind trump pulling
their masks off
just everything going wrong olivia
states
the bike
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
now it's probably a rhino is operating
they're having a bad day today they're
having a bad day but we're having a good
day
thank you these rallies have become
parodies of themselves truly
and i the audio issues continue
this next video i don't know why this
next one i found so funny
i was crying from laughter last night to
the po as i was preparing
this clip to the point where my
girlfriend came up to my office and
started filming me
watching this clip and laughing
hysterically i don't know why i find
this so funny
but i do and our incredible oh these
people don't know what the hell they're
doing
let me recover my ears for one second
[Applause]
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
these people there's also something i
mean it's horrible
but it's also in a way very trumpian
to immediately start attacking workers
saying they don't know what the hell
they're doing as far as
audio equipment is concerned one audio
tech sent me a message on twitter saying
uh i'm an audio tech the whoever is
working the audio is really doing god's
work by interfering with donald trump's
speech
and then under the category of complete
and total lies just complete lies that
make no sense
donald trump claims that joe biden wants
to ban weddings
graduations and even thanksgiving
[Applause]
with sleepy joe there'd be no
graduations no weddings no thanksgiving
they're already talking about no
thanksgiving
and in california you have a special
mask you cannot
under any circumstances take it off you
have to eat through the mask
do you think anybody really believes
that
or are even his supporters seeing it as
sort of performance theater meant just
to get a reaction
and then at the earlier rally trump
complained
as i mentioned not about the heat but
about
the wind you know it's windy as hell out
here
you know i said is it windy should i
bring a hat
because i don't love my hair flopping
around one thing
at least they figured out after three
years that it is mine if it wasn't i
would have found out about it today
just stay home maybe like don't do the
rallies if it's either too windy or too
hot or too cold or too sunny or too dark
just stay home and don't do it because
quite frankly all you're really doing is
spreading coronavirus
and in some cases giving old folks
hypothermia
and these are all trump voters anyway
you're not convincing anybody with these
rallies
i would say just stay home the next five
days he doesn't plan to though that's
for sure
president donald trump's son-in-law and
senior adviser jared kushner
bragged in april as the country was
reopening under donald trump's direction
about how donald trump took control
back from the doctors understand
what this means here is jared kushner
bragging to bob woodward
apparently having ill-advised
conversations with bob woodward runs in
the trump family
here is jared kushner bragging about
this the last thing was
kind of doing the guidelines which was
interesting and that in my mind was
almost like you know it was almost like
trump getting the country back from the
doctors right in the sense that
what he now did was you know he's gonna
own the open up there were three phases
there was the panic phase the pain phase
and then the comeback phase that doesn't
mean there's not still a lot of pain and
there won't be pain for a while
but that basically was we've now put out
rules to get back to work
trump's now back in charge it's not the
doctors they've kind of
we we have like a negotiated settlement
taking the country
back from the doctors during a global
pandemic we need
the doctors imagine saying we've got to
take the airplanes back from the pilots
all of these checklists and
fuel calculations and talking about what
do we do if we have to do an emergency
we gotta take control back from these
pilots we'll cut down the turnaround
time by 30 minutes each way
and will be able to fly an additional
flight every single day that's
essentially what they're saying here
let's take the clearing of toilet
backups
back from the plumbers my friends it's
time to get these over
confident idiot plumbers out of here
that's a phrase jared kushner will use
in this next clip
remember when they said what was it we
need a businessman running the country
like a business
well he saw himself as negotiating with
doctors
to get more deaths in exchange for some
businesses opening take a listen
the most dangerous people around the
president
are over competent idiots right because
that has a way sometimes of getting past
his defense mechanism because if you're
overconfident
then sometimes you know on a topic where
he doesn't have other people around to
kind of validate it
then he can sometimes say okay let's go
with that so that's kind of
i think if you look at the evolution
over time we've gotten rid of a lot of
the overcompetent idiots
and now he's got a lot more thoughtful
people who kind of know their place and
know what to do
the most dangerous people around trump
are over confident idiots
like jared not like the doctors instead
they want people who know their place
like for example
doctors who will let trump do whatever
he wants people like
scott atlas who is actually the epitome
of an overconfident idiot
a neuroradiologist who was brought in
to deal with an infectious disease but
scott atlas knows his place
very revealing comments from jared
kushner and then this next one is really
just
stunning it's kushner confirming exactly
what i've been saying for years
about both donald trump and his
followers it's not about
issues it's not about policy it's about
attitude
it's about pissing people off and
kushner says it listen to this
and so you know you look at like the
republican party platform it's a
document meant to like piss people off
basically more
you know it's done by activists yeah so
you have a disproportionality between
what issues people are vocal on and
and what the people the voters really
care about and what trump's been able to
do is i i say he basically did a full
hostile takeover of the republican party
and i don't think it's even as much
about the issues i think it's about the
attitude
just jared kushner completely laying
bare
every one of our worst suspicions about
these people and it's been obvious for a
long time
that this had happened but to hear them
say it so overtly is chilling
trump claims to be a great businessman
jared kushner a great businessman and
yet
they don't realize that the way to get
the economy back
is not to reopen prematurely it was
always
to deal with the pandemic that would
naturally fix the economy
they've never understood it and so it
just goes on and on
and now trump is endlessly repeating oh
biden wants to lock everything down
fouchy wants to lock everything down
everyone but
trump wants to take away your freedoms
but the goal isn't to lock down and
restrict freedoms
it's let's unite against a common enemy
and deal with the pandemic to save both
american lives
and to save the economy in the long term
the economy would naturally recover with
the pandemic under control and instead
this administration has said let's get
the doctors out of here
let's force openings because the focus
was
i guess short-term gains even though i
believe it has completely backfired
let's see if the election results bear
that out
and you know at the tail end of this if
you open too early
you're almost guaranteeing another
shutdown and even if it's not an
official shutdown
it's people who are going to stay home
here in massachusetts as cases have gone
from 150 a day to 300 600 1200 and now
even more
things are remaining open because it
doesn't seem there's any political
willingness to start shutting things
down
but people are staying home more and
more because they see the numbers and
that's the reality
you can't shortchange actually dealing
with
the problem and focusing only on
haphazardly fixing uh the symptoms
um but it just doesn't work and it's not
worked and we're seeing it now
we'll continue discussing this on the
show's
instagram david pakman show and if
you're on instagram
you might as well find me on instagram
at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today eric
garcetti who is the mayor of los angeles
california also national co-chair for
joe biden's campaign
played an integral role i am told in the
selection of kamala harris
as the vice presidential running mate
for joe biden
uh to start with mayor as you've watched
the first presidential debate and the
vice presidential debate
i know that we partisans tend to see
much of what we want to see in terms of
who does who does best but
analyzing it in terms of whether it
moved the needle at all what what do you
think
you know i think it reinforced what
people think about these candidates
in the first debate i was there in
cleveland it was the first trip that i
took i had no idea
i would be exposed to uh covet 19 by our
commander-in-chief and
and his uh some of his supporters and
family
that said just if you even turn
down what the words say watching
somebody interrupt
uh the other candidate when donald trump
was interrupting joe biden it showed
that he didn't have respect not only for
him as
his opponent but for us you know i'm
somebody who's run for office i think
it's important for you to hear what i
have to say
and what my opponent has to say because
if you have the strength of your ideas
you don't need to interrupt people and i
think
that's really the biggest contrast is
you know especially with
women who are now almost 30 points ahead
with people are just sick and tired of
the chaos
that trump has brought to this country
and he brought that same chaos to the
stage
the vice presidential debate while it
came in a slicker package
while certainly you have an accomplished
debater
in vice president pence uh he barely
answered the questions
um it was i called it flies and lies
because of the famous fly that lie
that landed on his head but all kidding
aside you know
he also interrupted this is the playbook
you know talk over people
and deny you know the science deny when
it comes to
climate change or covert 19 deny the
facts and try to reshape them
and i think people are finally seeing
through that you can maybe convince
people before you're in power
but after four years when they can
materially see what you've done to
damage the economy
how many lives have been lost and we
feel that in a personal way i think
there's never been a clear contrast in
an election in our lifetime
yeah and and i think on the vp debate
the fact that the most memorable moment
involved in insect um
tells us you know quite a bit really i
mean it's funny but it's also a real you
know a real real consideration
um one of the sort of uh concerns that
exists
when looking at the joe by what what joe
biden's first term would look like if
indeed
he gets one is that while on paper and
i've made the case that on paper joe
biden's platform
would make him the most progressive
president in history i mean on climate
he's to the left of obama
on health care he's to the left of obama
no i don't think there's any doubt there
when the news is that he's looking at a
pretty significant number of republicans
for the cabinet
you start to see some of those reluctant
maybe bernie supporters
warren supporters who do plan to vote
for biden worry
that the paper platform will not
really translate to a cabinet what is
your take on that
well first of all somebody who
co-chaired the vice presidential search
says i would believe
nothing of the what we used to call in
the navy rumor intelligence we called it
rument
there's a hundred rumors for everything
that's going on though i do believe that
those are not mutually exclusive i do
believe that
we will see and joe biden a president
for all of america unlike donald trump
who
looks at a state paints it a color and
decides whether he's going to help
we do need a president who will govern
for everybody regardless of whether
they're democrat
independent or republican but that
doesn't and it won't come at the expense
of the policies we've laid out in other
words we haven't put platforms out there
that we're going to run away from in an
administration you will see joe biden
kamala harris see through
you know getting to carbon neutral
electricity in this country by 2035
something unthinkable
to hear out of a presidential candidate
just a few years ago you will see a
massive infrastructure investment in a
new green infrastructure but i do think
it's important to have a cabinet that
reflects america
that has been a tradition generally
where you have in republican
administrations a democrat or two
and vice versa in a democratic
administration a republican or two
because
you want to have that unity in the
country but that's not going to come at
the expense of what we're going to do on
health care on housing
what we're going to do on the
environment when it comes to racial
justice those things
are part of why joe biden's running for
president and what this campaign is all
about
and what we're going to do when he wins
yeah and i guess
to the extent that nothing is given up
in order to have
a republican or two i i think that it
makes
makes a lot of sense i guess the concern
comes in
when you see very ambitious climate
proposals as
as you're pointing out if you have a
republican
secretary of transportation and energy
it starts to become it starts to at
least seem like it would be less likely
but you
you think it will be modestly calibrated
and this is not going to be
uh some some actual centrist cabinet
no not not at all i mean i look it's
good to have diverse perspectives but
when you run with a platform your
platform is your blueprint
and you don't run away from that no
matter what so you hire people who are
interested
in the boss's vision the boss is joe
biden
this isn't something done by committee
he has said if you
trust me as your next president this is
what i will
do there is no hedging of that 100
percent full stop
that is what this administration will
bring to america
not because it scores political points
it's what we need our earth is burning
our fires are record
uh our air is choking we're seeing
floods everywhere
you know i chair c40 cities which is the
96 largest
uh mayors sorry cities of the world's
mayors
combating climate change so i see this
every single day talking to folks from
japan and china and india and africa and
south america and australia
this is real and finally we're going to
see an administration that steps up to
this moment not just restores
our signing on to the paris climate
accord but takes many steps
forward and engages the international
conversation that we need
it's also one last thing good not just
for the environment but good for our
economy
this is where job growth is occurring
that's what we've experienced in la with
our green new deal
in los angeles and we will see at the
national level that same progressive and
green vision
um last thing i want to touch on from
the standpoint of
how this election is going to actually
happen we're seeing record early voting
although we don't want to read too much
into that because we've seen
record encouragement of early voting in
the context of the pandemic i wouldn't
look too much at that we're seeing
national polling that looks solid for
joe biden
but this is an electoral election not a
popular vote election so we want to be
careful there
and when you look at some key states
like pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
two weeks out right now compared to two
weeks out four years ago
it's actually quite similar the numbers
are quite similar from what we had
between hillary clinton and donald trump
in those key states
so question one what are you looking at
in terms of your assessment
and and number two when do you think we
will have election results the president
has fear-mongered around it could take
months
i don't believe that for a second but it
could take days it could take 10 14 days
what kind of timeline are you looking at
so those are great questions david and
you know i do think something's a little
different than four years ago i think
people are less shy about
answering in polls whether they're going
to be voting for donald trump and i do
think that this has been about as steady
polling as i've ever seen in an election
even
even in 2016 it was up and down and this
has been just
constant i think people are locked in
but we've never had an election like
this we've never had an election in a
pandemic
in the modern era we don't know how
those votes will be counted you're right
it's easy to see the early voting but
those are the most enthusiastic people
who know how to vote who are motivated
to vote and it's really about those
folks that are busy with their lives who
are stressed by the economic situation
who might not know how to vote by mail
and have never done it those are the
folks we're really focused on and
regardless of your party
i hope everybody can protect those votes
and encourage those votes
we're using the portal iwillvote.com
where you can find out all the
information in your
state about how to vote and make a plan
to do that
um and i think that if that is executed
we will win this but in terms of when
we'll know
you know there's some states that are
key swing states that are
able to start counting those votes early
in places like ohio so they're already
doing that as they receive them
other states and florida as well other
states go a little bit more slowly
and take some time in places like
pennsylvania so it all depends on what
that margin
is but i do think that look i i believe
very strongly we're ahead in
every swing state we're going to win
arizona i feel with confidence if we can
execute these last couple weeks
we're going to see potentially some
pickups of new states we haven't seen in
a while
be in the democratic column and maybe
bring some back that have strayed
so we have so many different paths to
victory for joe biden
uh you know donald trump has to run the
table
and i hope that part of running the
table for him is not denying the vote
it is not uh looking at trying to
encourage
uh supporters to depress the counting of
the vote like we saw
uh in florida during the bush gore
debacle
this is a moment which all of us as
americans need to respect the vote joe
biden said if i win or lose i will
respect the vote
we still haven't heard that out of the
words of the president so it falls on
us to save our democracy if our
president won't yeah on
on that note and i know i know you've
got a run we know that the trump
campaign has lawyers ready
to challenge the counting of absentee
ballots and and basically go to the
courts
at midnight on november 3rd are you
confident that the biden campaign
is also prepared sufficiently with
lawyers to challenge that
absolutely we have 17 states set up
we've been doing it for months we have
so many lawyers activists other people
who have volunteered who will do it the
right way this is not about mob
rule this is not about pressuring folks
to count or not count this is about
looking at each one carefully making
sure
every state no matter who runs the
elections adheres to the law and that
every vote is counted that's the most
basic right that we all have as
americans
i hope we can all stand up for that but
for those who would attack it we
are prepared yeah listen if joe biden
loses fairly
we will deal with that um but if it's a
different scenario then that's a very
different uh america that that we're
talking about we've been speaking with
eric garcetti mayor of los angeles
california
thank you so much for your time today
thanks david really great to be with you
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
you just have to hear this completely
ridiculous turn of events in the hunter
biden conspiracy theory tucker carlson
fox news host and propagandist now
claims
that he had obtained the absolutely
final devastating smoking gun documents
that would completely
nail and destroy hunter biden and by
extension joe biden
but the documents were lost in the mail
can you believe that check out tucker
carlson explaining this
then i'll catch you up on the details of
everything that's going on here
there's always a lot going on that we
don't have time to get to on the air but
there's something
specific going on behind the scenes
right now that we did feel we should
tell you about
so on monday of this week we received a
from a source a collection of
confidential documents related to the
biden family
we believe those documents are authentic
they're real and they're damning
at the time we received them our my
executive producer justin wells and i
were in los angeles preparing to
interview tony babilinski about the
biden's business dealings in china
ukraine and other countries
so we texted a producer in new york and
we asked him to send those documents to
us in la and he did that
so monday afternoon of this week he
shipped those documents overnight to
california with a large national carrier
a brand name company
that we've used you've used countless
times with never a single problem
but the biden documents never arrived in
los angeles
tuesday morning we received word from
the shipping company that our package
had been opened
and the contents were missing the
documents had disappeared
now to its credit the company took this
very seriously and immediately began a
search
they traced the envelope from the moment
our producers dropped it off
in manhattan on monday all the way to 3
44 am
yesterday morning that's when an
employee at a sorting facility in
another state
noticed that our package was open and
empty apparently it had been opened
so the company's security team
interviewed every one of its employees
who
touched the envelope we sent they
searched the plane and the trucks that
carried it
they went through the office in new york
where our producer dropped that package
off they combed the entire
cavernous sorting facility they used
pictures of what we had sent
so that searchers would know what to
look for they went far and beyond
but they found nothing those documents
have vanished
as of tonight the company has no idea
and no working theory even
about what happened to this trove of
materials documents that are directly
relevant to the presidential campaign
just six days from now we spoke to
executives at that company a few hours
ago
they seemed baffled and deeply bothered
by this
and so are we there is just so much here
and this is actually fascinating because
the disappearance
of the supposed documents that are
supposedly damning
has become part of the conspiracy when
he says a carrier you know it could be
usps more likely he means fedex or ups
my guess is if this had been usps
he would be very clear that it was the
postal service so i assume this was ups
or federal express
uh the idea is the fact
that the documents were lost is
part of the conspiracy to suppress the
information but understand that
every aspect of this is completely
indefeasible here's a conspiracy theory
well here are counterpoints for example
as were presented on fox news
a day ago to rudy giuliani when
interviewed on fox business
here's count here's a counter point to
what you're saying rudy
your questions are part of the
conspiracy to suppress
the story we are telling well there's
really you can't
you can't really prove that that's not
the case but there's no evidence for it
we had documents and they were damning
but they got lost and the fact that
someone
implicitly the idea is someone took them
that's part of the proof now that the
documents were damning
except we can't show you the documents
because we don't really know
now as a reminder this is the conspiracy
theory about hunter biden
that starts with hunter who lives in
california flying across the country to
get three laptops fixed at a repair shop
run
by a blind guy who says because he's
blind
he didn't actually see hunter biden drop
off the laptops
but he believes it was hunter biden
despite the fact that the person didn't
claim to be hunter biden
because one of the laptops had a sticker
on it
for the bo biden foundation which is
a hunter's late brother and for some
reason
after flying across the country to have
his three laptops repaired it sounds
like a comedy skit
hunter never picked the laptops up so
the blind repairman who wasn't actually
even sure
who who didn't actually see hunter biden
but somehow believed that it was
naturally turned the laptops on
red hunter biden's private emails and
made copies of what was on the hard
drives
and then sent the hard the laptops to
the fbi
but the fbi according to the repairman
didn't do
anything with the laptops so the
repairman a while later
said i know i'll call rudy giuliani and
give him the material i copied from the
laptops
that story where hunter biden for some
reason has three laptops repaired at a
shop 3000 miles from where he lives
and then never goes back and gets the
laptops that's the genesis
of this story now with tucker carlson
losing the documents now as far as the
documents
are concerned nobody makes a copy nobody
takes
pictures of each page with a cell phone
you send the only copy you have across
the country with no
backup what does fox think that their
viewers are this stupid where they're
now what the
the dog ate my homework stage of the
conspiracy theory
honestly guys the proof was really
damning but we lost it and you're just
gonna have to take our word for it
does anybody also believe by the way
that fedex or ups a major carrier
launched
carried out finished and reported on a
full investigation across multiple
states
in 24 hours does anybody believe that
have you ever reported missing
a book to fedex or ups do you have any
idea how long it takes
to do these investigations now very
important reminder here for everyone
thinking
tucker wouldn't lie about this in
defending tucker carlson
in a lawsuit fox news lawyers argued in
september
the things tucker says on his show
should not be interpreted as facts
it is entertainment that's actually the
defense fox news lawyers used
in court in a lawsuit a month ago you
can't
literally believe the things tucker says
because it's not it's
it's it looks like news but it's merely
entertainment so in truth
this entire story could be made up
because tucker's show
is entertainment it's amazing it's an
amazing time we live in
speaking of which there's a christian
televangelist pastor
scam artist really named kenneth
copeland we've spoken about him before
he is a really successful scammer i've
mentioned before that
the same cult-like behavior we see in
donald trump's followers is what we see
in the followers of other cultists
and some of these christian
televangelists and folks like kenneth
copeland are really great examples of
that and copeland
previously during the pandemic finished
the virus live on television
commanding god to destroy it he also
claimed to heal viewers through the
television
and generally has scammed his
disproportionately elderly followers in
really
immoral ways and he makes a ton of money
doing it the grift
reportedly has given kenneth copeland a
net worth of 300 million dollars well
the new one is that since donald trump
has recovered from coronavirus
not only is trump now immune but
christians
are all now immune from the virus take a
look at this clip
i was noticing today
president trump this beautiful
first lady without masks
they are immune right
they are immune
and this display
of our president giving god thanks
and for for helping him in that that
time and he walked out
immune that's right somehow
glory to god whoa thank you
jesus yeah amen oh hank come on man some
where hey we're we're immune that's
right
that's right
we're going through this thing with a
holy spirit
immunity from the works of the
devil you know uh i don't believe in
demons
but seeing video of kenneth copeland
makes me think maybe they do exist i i
have to tell you it's causing me to
doubt some of my beliefs
in a sane world he would have no
followers
in a sane world there wouldn't be 300
million dollars
in what he is doing we could simply
laugh it off and say
let's move on to the next thing this is
a funny thing to watch with my morning
coffee but this guy has
followers and trump has tens of millions
of followers and we have a country
where you can become really rich by
telling people lies like this
we have a country where you can become
president by bamboozling
your followers and encouraging them to
do
risky things like just go out there even
though there's a global pandemic
and if kenneth copeland's elderly
christian followers
believe they're immune because he says
it maybe they go without a mask
maybe they do large gatherings indoors
and do all the things that they
shouldn't be doing
and this is also odd because cemeteries
are filled with christians who died from
covet
is the idea that the christians only
became immune
after trump recovered well even that
doesn't make sense because
even after trump's recovery from covid
christians continue to die
of the virus this is scary stuff and
when i see video of kenneth copeland
i almost start looking for holy water to
douse myself with
it's really jim jones even kim jong-un
sort of territory and one thing
i've been thinking about i don't have an
answer but i want to hear from you
should some aspect of what kenneth
copeland is doing be illegal now i'm not
suggesting it should be necessarily
i'm not suggesting limiting speech i'm
not suggesting we violate the first
amendment but
is there some basis on which some
aspect of what kenneth copeland is doing
should be against the law
let me know what you think i want to
hear from you and the basis of it would
be
the potential and actual harm that it
creates
um there are many who say hey listen buy
or beware
and if you want to buy what he's selling
by sending him money or whatever uh
that's really up to the individual so
that's that's my question that i leave
you with
should some aspect of this be against
the law
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh sometimes i play voicemails that have
something nice to say sometimes
voicemails that have something not nice
to say
sometimes voicemails with a political
observation or a question
over the last couple of months we have
been getting more
and more and more just vile
disgusting unhinged attack voicemails
and i'm going to play one of those for
you today
i don't do this lightly i actually think
we need to understand the level of
escalation
that we are likely to see if donald
trump loses and claims it was rigged
okay because it is going to be
aggressively weaponized
just listen to this and imagine it 20
million times over
okay listen yeah david i just saw your
video about
rudy giuliani and you going on that he's
lying
and you're basing it on on what you have
no facts that he is lying
uh the fact is that hunter biden is a
crackhead
and the biden family is
corrupt criminals and
this is facts and
you're going on tv like you know you're
talking about
but in fact you don't so you should
either base what you say on facts
and or shut up
because you sound like a little [ __ ]
and i don't appreciate it
trump 2020 loser so
that is what i'm willing to play for you
because
there's 10 others we've sent to the fbi
because it's another level altogether
and so when i do the show and i say
i am genuinely worried about violence in
the real world
if joe biden wins and trump convinces
his followers that it was rigged and
unfortunately at this point
i think trump could even say nothing
after the election he said enough before
it that many of his followers will react
as if it was rigged regardless
i do think we need to be concerned about
violence in the real world
i do believe that for the most part our
systems will be able to
deal with it um but it but it is a real
concern
and i've been getting messages from
folks all over the country
about the aggressive intimidation they
are already seeing
and you know yesterday with with doug in
my interview with douglas murray
he said oh you know we we have things
are crazy because
people can't disagree with one another
anymore and of course the
implication for many of these folks is
that the left will not tolerate anybody
who is conservative
look at the degree of not just
intolerance but violent hostility
from trump is there are plenty of people
in the deep red states in deep red
counties who are planning to vote or
have already voted for joe biden
they are deathly afraid of telling
anybody so it is a problem
but it is not the one-way problem that
some on the right claim it to be
so very very scary stuff let's all
do everything we can to stay safe over
the next five days and beyond
on today's bonus show the cdc has
studied mask wearing and has found that
young people
are the most unlikely to wear masks
we will discuss that and more uber
is now being sued because it's star
rating system for drivers is accused of
being racially biased we're going to
talk about the allegations and whether
they
hold up at least superficially and then
how a court might weigh the allegations
and 80 million people have already voted
texas
over the next 24 hours will likely
achieve more
than the total 2016 voter turnout
in early voting early in person
and mail-in voting we are going to look
at the numbers we are going to look at
the party
division it is incredible the numbers
that we are seeing
two ways to access the bonus show become
a member
at joinpakman.com or become a patron
at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i look forward to seeing
you on the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist
the app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video